okay right the state of screenwriting in
2014 is very diffuse it's losing the old
boundaries between screenwriter director
screenwriting and television writing
this year our speakers have reflected
the multidisciplinary approach to
filmmaking so we have James Shamus
producer executive of Focus Features for
many years and a renowned screenwriter
Emma Thompson award-winning actor
screenwriter Steven Knight award-winning
writer and director I think this year
you're gonna see three very different
lectures far more diverse than in the
past
what Stephens done in his career is
moved from creating game shows to
writing original screenplays to now
directing and writing original
screenplays and that journey that he's
gone on is something that the audience
are gonna gain a great deal of insight
from I think Stephens gonna shed light
on the difference between writing
Hollywood and writing for the indie
scene because he's experienced in both
and he's not defensive about either you
might want to get a pen and pad ready
because Stephens gonna bring you some
very very powerful insights that you can
use Stephen thank you so much for giving
us this hour hour and a half um there
seems to be so much to cover but I think
we'd better start in a very very simple
place at the very beginning you are
particularly celebrated I might say
infamous for having created Who Wants to
Be a Millionaire
you went from that to dirty pretty
things which seems in anybody's language
a quite an extreme jump could you talk
us through that jump yeah I mean I was
doing two things at once for quite a
long time I was doing television and
writing novels and the television was
for a production company that did comedy
and drama and also game shows so you
could on any given day walk up a flight
of stairs and present a game show ideas
myself and two other people might whiter
than David Briggs we did game shows now
and again and some of them did okay and
then this one just went insane and
really became successful in the US but
at the same time pretty much exactly the
same time I was writing the fourth novel
and for some reason I was writing in the
present tense and it was just a
description of a of a scene in a hotel
and when I read it back it felt like a
screenplay so I thought I would do as a
screenplay instead so I wrote that and
then presented that at around the same
time and nothing happened for a while
and then it was what was the screen
scratching script factory did a reading
which was great and that helped and then
Stephen Frears picked it up and then he
got made so that the two things would
have happened a lot of luck and
coincidence and stuff yeah
and so Deborah Dean's was actually the
first full-length screenplay you'd
written yeah you haven't done a couple
of drafts of something else first
no okay and did you was this about how
different was the sort of TV comedy mm
TV comedy drama and also you've done
sort of stand at writing and you done
millionaire I mean how different was
that world from the slightly unforgiving
nature film world that you then found
yourself in I mean comedies unforgiving
as well I mean he perhaps even more so I
mean I started writing comedy for TV and
also for standards and in the early days
for people like Ken Dodd
Frankie Howard old-school surreal
brilliant comedians who had got these
acts that they had put together over 40
years and it perfected it every single
if you saw them if you saw any of those
old comedians on a different night
everything would be the same identical
because they knew what would make people
laugh and they knew what would put
people off and so from that experience I
sort of learned that even if you're not
trying to make people laugh there's an
absolute right we're in the wrong way of
doing something of saying something and
a joke is the perfect thing but you know
moving into drama was like that
because you're not constantly trying to
make the audience make that noise that
if they don't make it you're dead mm-hmm
and what about the sort of developments
and support systems to kind of get you
know all those kind of products projects
out you know some third game show a TV
drama a feature film script I mean what
how did you navigate your way through
the film in my mind I had to my mind in
reality had two computers so there was
two different worldviews yeah exactly
and one paid the bills and was the TV
stuff but the the novels were replaced
by the screen in other words that was
the sort of dreamy end of things that
was the stuff that I was doing for
myself and the screenplays when when
degree things took off it was possible
for me to just concentrate on
concentrate on that and then from then
on that's pretty much what I did until
peaky blinders and you made it sound
very easy then when you said you know
and then I wrote those two pretty things
and then Stephen Frears and then
blahblah
I mean presume that was not like that
what it would tell us what you had at
the beginning like what did you start
with there you had your yeah I mean they
had the idea of which is how anything
that I do that an original begins with a
scene if you like or the set up sort of
thing and I've been in the BBC for
something I came out of the BBC
Broadcasting House and looked at you
know that hotel the Langham yeah and
just looked at that and thought about
that place and what it would be like
inside I went inside and there was a
what I assumed was an African not Porter
desk line and I wondered what it was
like at night and what would happen and
I so when I went home I started writing
that scene of someone sitting there and
then their phone rings and he hears
someone say she's dead she's dead
and then the fact and that was it that
was the original thought and then from
then on trying to think well what was
that call about them you know and what
who is he and why is he there and that
happened and I wrote the story and I was
quite pleased with it not in final draft
or in any legible form really but it was
just written and I presented it naively
thought well I'll send it to BBC Films
then
because I was working for the baby yeah
we're doing things for the movie see at
the time so that seemed a logical place
for it to go and that I got I got a
response and the script factory thing
happened and you know when it's not what
you do for a living you sort of leave it
alone a bit and you know you're not that
concerned about it and sometimes somehow
it gets a life of its own and it starts
to get momentum then it died a death and
and someone told me this will never get
made it's not the right time for this
all of that stuff and then and I sort of
accepted it and then Stephen Frears
called to say that he'd read it and he
liked it so I went to him and he said I
said yeah it's very good he said but
could you make the end better I said
okay here fine what good there you go
and that was it that was the script
music so he never told you what you
meant mother no no so what do you do
I've tried to make it better it's best
when you write something you see the
film in your head and the ambition is to
get as close to that film on the screen
as you possibly can letting go of the
script and letting other people take in
trace it's great I mean I've been lucky
that the directors are working we've all
been brilliant so they've improved the
script but they're different and
different when you're a writer is hard
to tell you and can you think back to
kind of at that point that you know what
were their sort of biggest challenges
you had I mean apart from understanding
what make it better might mean but what
did you know looking back it was great
and I wish all the script and meetings
were like that but at the time I thought
well that must be how it is you know
that you just you get given that sort of
freedom but Stephens a different kettle
of fish to most directors you know he's
got the clout and he if he says this is
going to work then people were there
other people involved it that that kind
of helped you in the process developers
executives yeah I mean people I mean
obviously once you give it to Steven and
Chris menges then it becomes a different
thing because it becomes their thing you
know and that's when you learn the value
of how really great directors take
material
get better but they make it different
it's not that the words change because
the words didn't change but it's the way
that it's performed and the way that
actors take it on which was all of that
whole first film was an education and
can you talk a bit about your attitude
to research you said you came out you
saw the hotel you went off and made it
all up I mean did you go and investigate
that world and have you done that with
subsequent project yeah with you know
Russian mafia
you have to because concrete actually
helped rather than it being something
that you think well I better do this I
guess otherwise I'll be told off so you
know I was when early stages of dirty
pretty things did and I decided that he
would be a doctor who was here illegally
so couldn't practice and therefore was
having to do menial job and started to
find out about how people made a living
and then found out about the organ
donors thing and you know that's not
something that probably would have
sprung to mind if I hadn't read about it
and then suddenly it becomes the most
obvious plot point that that's what
happens he's a doctor and again dragged
in to do in this sort of organ donation
and stealing of organs but the research
is vitally important however I do think
you have to sort of some edges Rick said
do the research and then to ignore it
and you sort of do that in other words
it's there somewhere you've got some
bits from it but you can't be too
restricted by it
do you find that can resume it can be
too distracting as well yeah you can but
you know it sometimes the reality where
everybody knows in their own life two
things can be happening at the same time
that are so radically different to each
other and normally in fiction you choose
like with Locke Tom had a cold when when
he turned up to start shooting normally
you would think well someone can't have
a cold and have their marriage break up
at the same time because you've got to
choose one of the other but in fact in
fact as they do but it can happen at the
same time so in the end we said he's got
a call so he's got a cold and that's
fine you know because that's what
happens in the world weird things happen
have you always been on set it sounds
like that's quite an unusual experience
don't know that Stephen Frears always
likes his writers go on set and that
presumably was a big part of your
learning curve it's a difficult thing
because there's no if you're just gonna
go one one day a week yeah you can't
turn up on that day oh that's wrong you
know you can't do another because you
can't just step in on a particular
treatment and make it point so you have
to accept that we just it's a social
occasion when you visit the city unless
you're there all the time
are you surprised were you surprised
then when you went on set and saw what
they were doing with your script no it
was not that it was it was the first
experience of a real education because
when I first saw the assembly the first
assembly I thought this is what this is
the work this is embarrassing this is a
nightmare honestly and I said to
somebody else that this is just and it
all it was it's that it's not the same
as you imagined it right and then people
watch it and they say that's really good
anything how they're just obviously
being nice yes you know because it's not
good and then other people who you don't
know see and they like it and you
realize you've been an idiot because all
that's happened is that the thing you
had in your head is diff it's different
somebody's done it differently and it's
better but because it's not the same
that fir the first time you see you
think now that's all wrong you know it
shouldn't look like that shouldn't be
another and then you sort of realize you
have to let go of that until recently
when I've thought well I'll try and do
the film that's in my head as well so
that's why I wanted to direct there is a
definite rhythm to a script that you
sort of get to know I always think the
openings got to really explode and asked
lots of questions and you've just got to
keep pulling the rug out from under
people's expectations and sometimes that
involves even swapping lines of dialogue
between characters so that they're
saying each other's lines sometimes that
provokes something that you weren't
expecting
I if possible try to make the opening of
the film an event or a decision which
causes the rest of the film to happen so
it's like the pebble that hits the pond
it's like
because of that moment in the even if
you don't realize it at the time when
you're watching it because of that
moment everything else happens and
wouldn't have happened he hadn't been
for that moment
so like we'd lock the indicates left and
then changed mind indicates right and
that's why the whole film happens and
not so much with the pretty things but
it was he decided he was going to be a
doctor who was here illegally so what
would he do would probably be a mini cab
driver so he was trying to get London
established in a way that he's it's like
not like you know Buckingham Palace or
something he was London of people
arriving and he behaving in a way that
isn't quite London he's a housing for
work and the opportunity to deliver a
line which in its environment is okay
which is you know I'm here to help
people let down by the system which
subsequently hopefully has an extra
meaning or a different meaning as the
film goes on and how slavish are you I
mean how how slavish you do you think
about structure I should think about it
more I mean it's not clever to not think
about it that's all
it's worked well so far no but sort of
does but the way I've tended to do
things is I just start writing anything
and just keep going and then really back
and then think what's it but this is for
an original if you're doing an
adaptation of a book or someone else's
idea or a true story then that's it's
different you know that what's going to
happen but it's an original idea I find
it's much nicer to just start writing
read it back and then think about what's
going and in the end you're right it's
it's not very economical because you
write a lot of stuff and then afterwards
impose some sort of structure on it but
the whole three act thing it's in
Hollywood you know you've got no choice
you have to do that you have to do the
three acts you have to do character arc
but can you look back on the scripts
once you've written them and see that
you have those elements sort of yeah I
mean the three acts is it does it is
really they're intrinsically there so in
a story I think
lyza is in the jokes you got the
punchline you got the setup and then
there bit in the middle but the rules of
the rules of the game are such that in
Hollywood people actually look for
evidence that the rules have been
adhered to you know where's the end of
the first act and you don't know and so
in the end you sort of invent one but
telling this I mean Locke is hopefully
not like that and it's much more just
one journey and with an adaptation with
a book or with real life you have
certain definite things that you have to
cover it and you haven't progressed in'
of story which you have to deal with so
that most recently with sound of foot
your journey is from a novel yet yeah
and how slavish ly were you know I mean
the thing with that if anybody's read
the novel it covers a much longer period
of time and it's it's much more about
Paris and and and in the end it was a
question with that of trying to find
where the film was in terms of what's
achievable because if it had been six
hours of television you could have done
the whole book but in a hundred-foot
journey it was finding the sequence
where they're in that little village
that's where you know it's taking just a
section of the book and making that into
the film so you do have to make the
decision of what if you're given about
what actually will work as a film
because they're two that's so different
to each other films and normals and
endings what's your tale do you know
you're in your Indonesia it's probably
it's usually a good it's the only bit of
discipline you have in a way if you know
what's gonna happen at the end at the
very end you you can be as free as you
want but at least you know which
direction you're going into
it's like Edward de Bono was did talk
about creativity where he said if you're
at home and you go to somewhere you've
never been it gets more and more
difficult because you're less and less
familiar with where you're going if
you're going home against more and more
familiar more and more easy and it's the
same with an ending if you know the
ending you're
towards it and it's sort of getting
easier and easier because you are
getting closer and closer to the
familiar territory that you've got in
your head somewhere not suggesting that
you write the ending but you know pretty
much where it's going to go but in the
middle that you can do anything
that's brilliant well no a problem with
it is if as I say it's like it would be
much more sensible to do a treatment and
stick to it right it would because then
you would save yourself so much time but
I did it's not something I've ever done
room for me dialogue is the thing that
makes me want to do it and I'm always
drawn to films a dialogue heavy like
Who's Afraid of Virginia Woolf that's
one of my favorites so yeah that's what
I see a script has dialogue the worst
thing you can do is to say the character
walks in he's got and he's got to convey
this piece of information so he walks in
the room and conveys this piece of
information in any no matter how you
dress it up that's what they're doing
it's it's much more interesting to try
and leave as the character and I know it
sounds ridiculous but try and even let
them say what they're gonna say and
sometimes you end the scene and you
haven't got anywhere you know you
haven't got anywhere closer to conveying
the information but the scene it needs
okay because you've had this
conversation between two people that
feels real if you can try and get close
to that is good in dialogue but also I
think it's being aware of the amount of
stuff that doesn't get said and
imagining that the mountains and
mountains and mountains of stuff that's
in people's heads when they may
especially men a man and a woman who are
attracted to each other and there's so
many things not said that you can't say
there are rules against saying disliking
Locke you know when you're talking to
your son about something or something
really emotional is happening talk about
football you know talk about someone
else I talk about the motorbike or
something then sometimes that's what
people do I think you go for something
hard especially men I think you go for
something you know solid to talk about
because I think men talk about things
and objects more
then women do and they need if they need
a place to hide and so they'll go for
football or the motorboat or something
and I think if you can be aware of how
people do that and the tricks people
play on each other when they're having
conversations and sometimes just put in
anything just anything people can say
anything you never know you know when
you if you see a transcript of a real
conversation it's all over the place
people say the oddest things but in the
odd things that they say you know the
example I would give him in when I was
much younger I worked on a building site
and there was a there was a tea boy and
he came and came in with a tray of tea
and everybody in the in the hope
everybody was working everybody took one
there was none left for him and he's
exact words were are bastard make the
bastard and I don't bastard get a
bastard don't cease the exact words
and what about exposition then it's
horrible
see see plot yeah it's horrible because
sometimes you have to get it other way
right so how do you solve those problems
where you have to convey and invent a
character who knows nothing a character
who knows nothing about whatever it is
so that you have a legitimate reason to
explain to the character really
obviously explain to the audience but
and also formal situations where someone
an MIT police procedures the stuff is
great because you've got a real reason
to be very specific amazing grace
you've got quite a lot of yeah you know
very very detailed information to get
over I talked about how you yeah to do
that I got there's one particular thing
where it's all about parliamentary
procedure and then Wilberforce and his
allies played this really clever trick
political trick in the House of Commons
but to explain it and I tried loads of
different ways and in the end it helped
if it was urgent because then you've got
a reason for saying it quickly and and
getting me out of the way but and then
it helped if it was in a place that was
not expected so I had the person who
they were explaining to playing golf and
he's standing there playing golf and
he's much more mature than the golf and
they're trying to get his attention so
they
we tell him in this information and how
written is your dialogue generally kind
of how how how happy are you for actors
to kind of take your words not know that
when you happen it's obviously a bit I'm
not happy about if Locke is all
word-for-word but as a writer I think
it's hot it's not you don't want them to
change anything you know you want it to
even the pauses and when you're
directing you have to do everything you
can not to try and just say it
in the way you want it said it which
would be deaf but that's what you I
think if you're a writer that's your job
to try and defend word-for-word but then
you have to accept that it isn't gonna
be like that and how much do you care
about kind of backstory there's somebody
much said oh you have to make your
characters do the very quick Mary Claire
quiz or you know yeah but like do you do
you know how much more do you give them
we see I don't really start off with
backstory I think the back story comes
bit by bit and as you write the
character of the scenes happen then I
think you you start to think of a reason
why they might behave like that and why
they might be like that and then by the
end you sort of almost got a complete
backstory for that character but along
the way
I wouldn't fill in the gaps too too much
before getting to the end I wonder if we
should pause and take some questions
from the audience
first up there yes I just wanted you
could talk a little bit about the length
of the sheep for Locke and and also what
was it was he really written as Welsh or
was that a choice no it was what seemed
to be from a working-class background so
that he could legitimately be from a
very poor background but a lot of the
accents we had to rule out Birmingham
Liverpool London all come with a lot of
baggage in all of them and also Ivan is
this character who calms people down he
deals with crises and Tom said the
person I know most like that he's Welsh
and that I will do him because he said I
don't do accents I do people that have
that accent so he said I'll do him and
he'll be Welsh so he did that which is
great
and he listened to under Millwood
Richard Burton a lot people and so got
all of that when the film came out a
Welsh newspaper track down the person
that he based thing on and they said how
does it feel that Tom Hardy based his
character on you he said it's fine but
I'm not Welsh he's not well sleepily
remembered him as well when you wrote
your first script did you keep your day
job and keep alive mmm so what so were
you they say I mean he overlapped a lot
of things are calling them but they
overlapped a lot where it was a period
of doing television dirty things and
they want to be a millionaire was taken
off as well so it was all getting quite
busy and then Eastern Promises happened
very quickly actually after that and it
was all going going well but in terms of
the day job I now think of writing
scripts as the day job and directing as
the funny and that you're somebody's
worked in both film and television and
you mentioned earlier about the sort of
requirements that Hollywood often puts
on you when you write a film about the
beginning middle and end and do you find
that television is a better environment
for writers than perhaps working in film
is at the moment there's more
opportunities definitely I mean you've
got more chance of getting stuff made I
think guess also there's this thing of
the writers table where the everybody
sits around you know you get lots of
writers working on a particular project
so you do get a chance to to actually
sit down and do stuff but if I were to
advise I would say try and do everything
but telly is probably more likely to be
the place where you'll get some paid
work it's not easy to find yourself
working for a Hollywood major how do you
negotiate if they get around
their obsession with the three-act
structure you don't you know I mean
there's no point that basically they've
they've come to you and said we want you
to write X but to you know so there is
that yet so that's what you're gonna do
and you've agreed to do it you know the
deal you know the parameters you know
also I mean personally I have no problem
with the way they operate because
basically they're running the business
they're not building a building they're
making some another a lot of fog and
mist and it's not solid and they they
want to know they're gonna at least get
their money back and the way the easiest
way to do that is make it similar to
something that's already made money so
that's you know they'll keep repeating
something until people stop going and
therefore you know that you know it's a
business and there's something good
about its you know I like Hollywood I
like go in there it's very simple it's
about money everything you know you know
it's about money it's fine and they're
good they're very good people and very
creative people but ultimately it's an
industry and you know they're there
because they they have to make money but
I think it's a bit like saying a painter
does a painting that everybody loves and
it's 40% blue paint so from now on you
have to paint paintings at a forty
percent blue because it worked before
you know I think that that's the putting
it at the most blunt that's sort of I
think the film industry which is why we
constantly but you know the bats and
spiders and superheroes and stuff in
there we're not quite i wouldn't you
just read this very short introductory
page from lock just so you can see that
kind of here the flavor and the richness
of the description would you yeah the
man gets into the driver's seat he's in
his thirties a face made of stone and
unused to expression or emotion this is
Ivan Locke he sits in the driver's seat
for a few moments he takes a breath and
we might guess or we might not that he
has just had some important news
is he scared angry question mark he
takes out his cell phone and looks
deciding whether or not to make a call
this is actually this never made it he
checks it he checks his watch he decides
there is time for a call he gets the
phone away quickly and far as the
engineer shifts gear in reverses we stay
with him on we'll stay with him
intensely for the rest of the story the
car bumps over rough ground as Ivan
heads for the big secure gates that open
out onto the street the construction
site is massive and it takes a while to
reach the edge of it trucks rumble and
generators roar this is Ivan's world the
gates are opened by a guy in a high biz
jacket Ivan reaches the curb of the road
and indicates right as a reflex but he
doesn't pull away he realizes this time
he must choose which way he will go he
has a decision to make but he's a man
who makes a hundred hard decisions a day
even so he takes time a massive truck
pulls up inches behind him and his
headlights fill Ivan's car
Ivan continues to make his decision as
his indicator ticks away the second the
truck hoots its baleful horn the voice
of fate Ivan hits the indicator to
indicate left instead of right he turns
left and joins light evening traffic
Ivan one hour drive through city streets
toward the m6 motorway and a couple of
miles away
we will not blink as we study him as he
drives he speed dials a number labelled
bastard
you
you